Today's stove cleaning day on my 1950s chamber stove.
I've been putting this off for a while.
So this is gonna be a deep clean.
I've been doing some touch up cleaning
but the last week I knew I was gonna deep clean it.
So I just been kinda letting it go.
This is the broiler top. It kinda acts like a Blackstone.
And here is the pilot light cover.
I'm gonna remove my handy dandy childproofing for the pantry area here.
And I did have a boil over of some chocolate syrup a few days ago.
So this is this disaster right here.
It spilled through the drip hand and catch it
and it went all over the place.
So we're gonna start from top to bottom.
I'm gonna take the grill crumb catcher out here.
I'm gonna take the hot plate off.
It does remove.
I'm gonna clean that and I'm gonna remove all the pieces that come off.
Now I'm gonna shut the gas off and blow the pilot light out.
I don't want the pilot light on as it's gonna keep getting warm
and I want it cool off where I'm cleaning everything.
Now these are the daisy burners.
They easily remove
and I'm gonna take those out and give them a little bit of maintenance.
The original enamel coating has started to deteriorate.
Do you wanna get them recoded?
But that's something that I'm not gonna do right now.
So I'm gonna touch them up.
With some high heat paint
to see if that will make them a little better.
I'm gonna put all the drip pans right now
into some soapy water to soak.
As I have this more. That chocolate syrup disaster right here.
This is the chocolate syrup again.
I need to scrub all this off and remove it.
Some of these spots are pretty stubborn.
I'm using just dish soap and some baking soda
to remove all the burnt on pieces on the chrome.
Now the drawer for the bottom of the pantry does come out
for the bottom piece. And so
that makes it a little bit easier
for me to get this chocolate syrup off.
It did make a huge mess.
I actually used a smaller pan than I normally would to make the syrup,
as I didn't wanna dirty up a new pan.
And it's actually made, obviously
way more mess than it would have been just to use the beer pan.
The designer, the stove
really makes me think that they actually spent a lot of time
when designing the stove
to think of all the things that you need to do
to clean it and use it properly.
Now I'm gonna wire brush the daisy burners
and get them a new coat of paint. Again.
Something I wanted to repair properly in the future,
but right now this is just a touch up.
And then I'm gonna clean and scrub with a griddle plate.
I'm not Gonna remove all of this
because it does create a nice nonstick seasoning to it,
but I do wanna make it look a little bit nicer and keep it clean.
I don't want the seasoning to build up to the point where it's black.
Now I'm going to reassemble the grill and close that,
and that part is finished.
And now I'm gonna reinstall the daisy burners.
I only gave these a few minutes to dry.
The paint dried really fast.
This is the part where the gas comes through,
and that's where you can adjust how much gas is flowing through,
which is really important.
If you have propane or natural gas,
you can literally just.
That's how you adjust the difference between the two.
And I'm gonna replace the drip pans.
They are super weird to reinstall.
They have, like,
a certain pattern that goes to them,
and sometimes they can be kind of annoying to put back in.
Like, it's not set up to put back in very obviously.
And I'm gonna get the front of the stove and wipe down
and the floor. Anything goes for these, um,
burner covers. I think that's what they're called.
Um, they have a certain pin system to them,
a pattern. So the longer pins hook into the holes to hold them in place,
but it's not very obvious which way they go.
And it's kind of a.
Kind of a waste of time sitting there trying to figure that Out.
Now all I need to do is relight the pilot light.
I only use one pilot light on the stove.
There is three, but I just use the one.
And I'm gonna be cooking some lunch,
so time to make it dirty again.